I also saw the American Gladiators thing
on Netflix guess what dude I'm gonna
come out and say it you're making too
many documentaries about things
when I first saw it I was like oh cool
and then I watched halfway through like
the third episode I go like this dude
I'm only watching this because I used to
watch the American Gladiators that's so
[__] stupid
that's so dumb what I did I go oh cool
click and I watched the whole thing and
I'm watching this thing and then they're
trying to play up like oh yeah these
guys were juicing these guys did drugs
and like they couldn't hack it and one
guy got fired another guy got fired and
the producers were trying to rip people
off and make money off the actors and
they believed in a franchise not
necessarily the the actors and they
thought that the franchise was a star
not the ACT not not [__] Nitro and
and and and and I'm watching this thing
and for about three episodes I'm like
wow wow okay pretty scandalous and then
I'm like oh but it's actually not it's
just boring and oh oh no [__] dude oh
really
Gemini ice [__] Nitro these big
Behemoth [__] oh oh they did
steroids no get out of here dude really
that's not news a [__] course the
American Gladiators did sterile droids I
wouldn't I wouldn't watch them if they
didn't how about that Juice It Up
take injections
[__] HDH do the whole steroid
do it all be a chick and do it be a
woman and talk like this
Come On Ice
oh really some of the women who did
American Gladiators were gay and it was
hard for them oh [__]
no [__] no [__] they were gay and
juicing
so watch this [__] thing and it's
like and then one guy took a big hit and
got that was it for him and they thought
Malibu was gonna be a big thing yeah
dude
that's not it and oh and the producers
tried to make money
and they were on they were they were
they were pissed off that the actors
were pissed off that didn't get
merchandising
dude this is just
how the biz goes
ah [__] huh
well whatever dude you know nobody died
I'm watching this and I'm like nobody
died
zero people died they just did steroids
this is [__] they're making
documentaries of too many things
dude Netflix will just [__] straight
put out
the garbage man conspiracy on [__]
Main Street and in [__] Seattle and
you're like what
and the whole [__] show was just
and then one guy you know they start too
early and they wake me up all the time
garbage man conspiracy
on Netflix
Eight Episodes
and people just eat watch oh eat oh
really
oh so they don't even really put the
plastic in the recycling dude did you
hear a garbage man conspiracy did you
know they don't put the plastic in the
[__] thing there was one unbelievable
story about the the American Gladiator
in that thing the dude Nitro really
handsome dude
um and this is just so telling
about
um
how Insidious trauma is right like when
you're a kid when you're growing up like
we've all had some sort of trauma and
um Pia Melody
who basically wrote the book on
childhood trauma was she did write books
on childhood drama but
she says anything less than nurturing is
trauma and I don't know if I believe
that but everything affects you when
you're [__] five so in a way I
understand what she's saying
um but this dude basically this kid
Nitro when he was a kid was ripped from
his mom his dad took him and he had to
leave his mom because his dad was gonna
take custody of him so he was getting on
the plane leaving his mom and his mom
was weeping and he was crying so much
right I don't know how old he was young
but this guy who saw the kid and said
hey buddy are you crying and he said
yeah and he says let me see your muscle
and the guy goes like this and he points
to it and he says you got a little
muscle right there that means you're a
man and Men Don't Cry
that [__] thing this guy he's 58 now
and he remembers that and that's I would
argue the reason he got big and jacked
and became American Gladiator isn't that
[__] insane and now he dude his
brother died years later and he didn't
cry he was like I'm not supposed to cry
because that guy said he was still a kid
but dude that [__] that little grain of
sand plucked into that dude's brain grew
to be a whole [__]
and now it's [__] up
but
Hopefully the guy knows and the guy did
therapy and the guy's [__] a little
bit better for it now because man here's
the other [__] crazy thing dude that
guy who told that kid Nitro as a kid
that isn't a bad guy he thought he was
helping that's the most [__] up like
do you don't even get to be like as an
adult as nitro you don't even get to be
like [__] that guy he's evil you got to
be like I was only trying his best and
now I'm [__] up
as you're on the [__]
the jousting
eyes are in the big ball like a [__]
big muscular hamster
yeah dude it's crazy trauma what it does
man
[Music]